Wall Street realized they could go from
being the bad guys after the 08 crisis
to be in the good guys if they just said
the right things
Muse about diversity and inclusion
meaning unjust impact of climate change
after you're flying a private jet to
Davos it's pretty good work if you can
get it it was a cynical arranged
marriage though between two partners in
that marriage that did not particularly
love or respect one another big business
in the in the neo-progressive work
movement but together they were each
able to get something out of the trade
it was more like Mutual prostitution and
that was what led to the birth of woke
Inc it wasn't just woke and it wasn't
just the ink it was it was both of them
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the co-founder of strive Asset
Management as well as the author of the
brand new book nation of victims
identity Politics the death of Merit and
the path back to Excellence Vivek
ramaswamy welcome finally to the Reuben
report
it's good to talk to you man how are you
I am doing well I have wanted to have
you on for quite some time and then
about I don't know it was about four or
five months ago I was hosting a Prager
event you uh a prageru event in uh in
West Palm and you were one of the
keynote speakers and you actually blew
me away You're a phenomenal public
speaker great way of connecting with the
audience uh talking about all the things
that I'm always yammering on about so
that's what I want to dive into on on
the show today uh but before we get into
business and why you're doing this in
the book give me a little uh vivec 101
little little backstory of little vivec
and what got him to be this power player
in uh in business and culture yeah I
don't know I I can't uh you know promise
all the answers but I can tell you a
little bit about my story I uh you know
I grew up in Cincinnati Ohio my parents
were immigrants from India my dad came
over in the late 70s my mom in the early
80s and uh you know we would frequently
joke around about why on Earth you came
Halfway Around the World to Southwest
Ohio and my dad's reason for coming was
that his older sister was in Fort Wayne
Indiana which of course begged the
question of why she came Halfway Around
The World of Fort Wayne Indiana and our
family joke is that it is the only U.S
state with the word India contained in
the name of the state so so that that
gives you a sense of what the upbringing
was corny jokes in the midwest uh and
that was uh you know the Immigrant
upbringing which I could you know tell
you all about some of that's in the book
actually but uh but anyway I ended up
going into science first I went to
Harvard studied molecular biology
thought I was going to be a scientist
ended up in the world of Biotech
investing which I did for seven years
from 2007 to 2014. about three years in
I had this itch to study law and
political philosophy I had been such a
science-centric guy that I told my
bosses that I was going to leave my
hedge fund job and and go you know go to
law school I had a seat at Yale they
said keep your job keep managing a
portfolio if you want I said that sounds
great so I did that for three years from
2010 to 2013. when I graduated I no
longer had law school on my on my docket
so I used the extra time for an
ignominious short-lived stint as a
stand-up comedian in New York City that
did not work out well it was humbling
what year what year was that that was
2013 and 20 early 2014. so 2013 was was
when I did my 10 shows I wonder man if
we cross paths at that time that was
like right around when I was in the
thick of it over there and uh do you
remember what company you were doing oh
yeah it used to be funny man long time
ago okay so I did like Broadway Comedy
Club a couple other places yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's that's pretty funny
then you're retired huh yeah and then I
hung the Jersey on that uh due to the
better advice of friends and family who
were you know very honest audience
members uh but anyway then I uh yeah
it's a long story but led me to the
doorstep of founding my company which
was a biotech company that you know all
the things that I saw from my career as
an investor that frustrated me as an
outside investor in biotech I wanted to
fix
decided to do it by starting a company
and so built the company LED it as CEO
from 2014 to 2021 we developed a number
of medicines some of them failed some of
them worked five of them are FDA
approved products today which I'm
incredibly proud of but at the end of
the day I ended up having to step down
in 2021 to focus on what I saw as a new
cancer a cultural cancer
that threatened the very dream that
allowed me to achieve everything I ever
had in my life and and you know look I
was worried about this new trend about
the merger of corporate power and state
power to advance political agendas
through the private sector I had some of
those first-hand experiences myself in
my experience as a CEO of a
multi-billion dollar biotech company
there were some demands that came with
it that I uh you know that I that I
thought were threatening to the system
of American capitalism and democracy and
so that led me to step aside to write my
first book which was woke Inc which I
think you might be familiar with I
published that book enjoyed for a year
and a half traveled out in the country
no agenda just speaking my mind freely
without any corporate agenda any
political agenda really enjoyed that
that led to my second book as well which
was a sequel to woke Inc that's the one
that we're talking about now
but I decided that I wasn't gonna just
change the world by writing books I
needed to do something about the
problems I was describing and that's
what led me also more recently to found
strive which is our new firm competing
directly against BlackRock so that's
that's sort of the life career Journey
all right you gave me a lot of avenues
to go down so let's back up for a second
because obviously I want to talk about
strive and I want to talk about the new
book but woking I mean basically uh you
know you were laying out that that this
woke thing that we were all seeing it's
going through the universities it's on
television everywhere you turn on Apple
TV that it's not just sort of this
organic thing coming from kids off
tumblr that there actually is an
organizational ideology behind it so can
you talk about that a little bit because
people always ask me either when I do q
and A's on the show where I go out
publicly where is it coming from what is
driving it truly
yes I mean look that took a whole whole
separate book length work to describe
but but one of the things I said in that
book was that it was when wokeness met
capitalism that it actually became
Unstoppable and it was supercharged with
the dollars that flow through our system
of free market American capitalism
that's when it really became not just a
challenge to the system it became the
system and it happened in the aftermath
of the 2008 financial crisis and I saw
this firsthand right I got my first job
at that hedge fund in New York City in
the fall of 2007 on the eve of the 08
crisis said and the long story short and
it is a long story and it was you know
it was my last book so we could we could
go on for hours about this one but the
short version of it
is that
Wall Street realized they could go from
being the bad guys after the 08 crisis
to being the good guys if they just said
the right things
Muse about diversity and inclusion
meaning unjust impact of climate change
after you're flying a private jet to
Davos
it's pretty good work if you can get it
it was a cynical arranged marriage
though between two partners in that
marriage that did not particularly love
or respect one another big business in
the in the neo-progressive work movement
but together they were each able to get
something out of the trade it was more
like Mutual prostitution and that was
what led to the birth of woke Inc it
wasn't just woke and it wasn't just the
ink it was it was both of them and
that's what that that whole tale was
about I will tell you that over the
course of writing that book though I was
interested in both the corporate
cynicism behind it which is what that
book ended up being about but I was also
interested in the content of the
underlying ideology as well and so the
publisher kind of told me an advisors
who helped me put that book together
said look you got to pick one or the
other start with the first one and then
and then actually The Unfinished work
was what led to nation of victims which
is which is the book that I'm putting
out now so you know that was that was a
bit of the Journey of the two books the
first one was really about the corporate
Financial fuel and and and the second
book is really about the underlying
flyer the con the fire the configuration
on which corporations through that fuel
and and together I think I assume that
the irony should not be lost on anyone
that as you describe it it was
capitalism that allowed this thing to be
Unleashed which is virulently
anti-capitalist
of course and and you know what
a famous economist uh in a schumpeter
Jose Trumpeter himself you know said
very said very similar things this is
early 20th century stuff from from V
from Von mises that capitalism creates
a psychological need
filled by anti-capitalism
you know Trumpeter kind of predicted the
same thing the system of creative
destruction but first capitalism give
Rock gives rise necessarily paves the
way to socialism that was kind of uh
schumpeter's thesis and it's it's
interesting you know we we see their
predictions play out in the moment that
you and I live in I mean you're
technically a millennial you're a
millennial as well I'm I believe I'm 46
my friend I am so you're on the other
side okay I am G you look good man so so
I don't know but I'm a millennial so I'm
I'm what 37 now so my generation I was
gonna say our generation we'll call it
my generation I have a lot of younger
friends
that's good you know whatever you get it
it's a spectrum anyway your generation's
sort of the younger part of your
generation counts in this is you know
but the Millennials in particular were
on the receiving end I mean I I I'm
personally not in the receiving end of
this but Millennials as a generation on
the receiving end of the largest
intergenerational wealth transfer in
human history and there's something
about that that creates this
psychological need for self-criticism
and criticism of the very system that
created the wealth that you're otherwise
going to be on the receiving end of but
without actually making the sacrifice of
giving up that inheritance be able to
apologize for it with this new
self-found consciousness of your of your
privilege or whatever it is that lies at
the heart of the apologism that
characterizes and I don't even use the
word woke anymore because it's sort of a
become a tired word but the modern
neo-progressive movement the apologist
culture that's that's really at the
heart of my next book which is the
victimhood culture that that permeates
our American fabric today are you
surprised that it rampaged through so
many businesses I mean businesses that
were were or should be based on actual
numbers it's one thing okay Rampages
through an entertainment company you
know somebody making movies TV shows Etc
but like seemingly everything accounting
terms and Banks like the whole freaking
thing that you know these are people
that actually have to look at numbers
and make sense based on reality or at
least are supposed to
yeah and you know at first it's
surprising of course it's
counterintuitive right that's that's why
it made for an interesting book but
and when you when you examine it it's
actually not surprising at all because
it serves the interests of many of the
people who are the property the biggest
propagators of this new ideology I mean
look Larry Fink at BlackRock used this
as a philosophy to aggregate over 10
trillion dollars so creating the world
assets under management that's something
that he couldn't have done if it weren't
fulfilling the void created by the 2008
financial crisis and telling people that
this was actually the new capitalism
itself and so you know I think the
people on top by the way without saying
in Iota about those same words in China
how do you know it's in their
self-interest you talk about ESG or Dei
or CSR or whatever your three favorite
three-letter acronym is when they go
over the other three letter acronym from
from ESG Dei and CSR to CCP to be able
to do business in China without saying a
peak about ESG or Dei because that's
what it pays to do over there now in the
United States had paid to do it because
Pension funds like California Calpers
you know state of New York they said
we're only going to do business with
firms that adopt these Progressive of
commitments well they said you know what
those are where the biggest checks are
coming from that's the tune we're going
to dance to and so in a certain sense
the economic incentives were set up that
way it wasn't altogether surprising that
people responded to those incentives I
think you know my new book is a nation
of victims we sort of talk about that I
talk about that at the individual level
as well why is victimhood culture so
rampant in the United States it's a bit
of a curiosity right you know we have
living in the most prosperous moments in
in human history and in American history
why is it then that we fashion ourselves
to think of ourselves as victims in
every given Direction black victims
white victims second generation Asian
victims I mean it's everywhere we've in
certain senses create an incentive
structure in our country that rewards
someone for characterizing themselves as
a victim rather than as a Victor and so
I I think that you know it doesn't it's
not it's not a sort of a Cheesy humans
respond to incentives kind of argument
all the way down but that is an
important part of the story and it's
certainly a part of the story that makes
it less surprising than you'd otherwise
think so I want to get to some of that
psychology behind that real quick just
to back up I think most of my audience
is following you on BlackRock and ESG
and some of the other stuff but for some
of the people that are missing maybe
some of the pieces here first off can
you explain uh sort of what black rock
is and how that is connected to ESG
we've talked a bit about ESG on the show
but I think we kind of lay it out
somewhat simply I think I think that'll
help some people
yeah absolutely so look you know the ESG
movement people hear This Acronym what
is it okay so it stands for
environmental social and governance
factors and it basically is a close
cousin of a broader movement called
stakeholder capitalism which refers to
the idea that businesses should not just
sell products and services for profit
but they should also Advance other
societal agendas and other social
interests okay that's the philosophy
agree or not that's what it says now
what that's become is a vehicle for
government actors to effectuate through
the private sector what they could not
effectuate through the front door of
policy making so so one example let's
take is is the climate agenda the green
New Deal whatever you may want to call
it the green New Deal did not muster
political support to be passed through
Congress well with the ESG move mentford
was a vehicle to lean on many companies
to sign what you call a climate pledge
instead get every company to voluntarily
voluntarily by the way I use that in
airports because it's with the invisible
fist of government behind it but to
voluntarily
adopt Net Zero standards and pledges by
2050. unilateral pledges to support the
Paris climate Accords and abide by its
demands even though the U.S did not
ratify the Paris climate Accords the
Paris climate agreement
the private sector effectively ratifies
it instead I actually this is an aside I
sent a public letter as a shareholder to
the board of Chevron earlier this week
complaining amongst other things about a
corporate Behavior about Chevron
embracing the Paris climate agreement
reminding them that the U.S did not
ratify this it is not chevron's job to
use shareholder Capital to ratify it
instead especially when it's not even in
the best interest of that business so
anyway that that's a bit about what this
is is you know let's just say even the
Silicon Valley censorship I actually
view that as a subset of this broader
problem of stakeholder capitalism and
the ESG movement people think about that
as a separate issue I've written
extensively about you know about that
issue about how government actors about
how private actors actually ought to be
bound by the First Amendment if they're
responding to government threats I you
know was talking about that before that
was cool back when it was ridiculed as
an idea about a year now sort of like
when Jen saki is admitting that the
government Flags posts about
disinformation for Facebook in essence
absolutely and then threatens companies
if they don't take down the posts that
they're going to be you know they're
going to be broken up that they're going
to bring antitrust action then companies
do it but they say hey it's not the
government doing it's just the free
market and and the First Amendment
doesn't apply to the free market it's
another example of government actors
using private companies to do through
the back door the Dirty Work of
government that it could not accomplish
through the front door under the
Constitution or with political
accountability so that's what this
movement effectively represents
now you know it sort of in a takes two
to tango Spirit it only works if the
consumers and individual investors Etc
in the economy still fall for it at the
end of the day if consumers would still
resist this and not buy those products
or individual investors who exercises
their voice not going to stand by this
Behavior you know this this couldn't
have existed but I think some of that
relates to a culture a moment of
cultural weakness and so I think I think
there's I think there's not one story
here but two story lines that are really
important one is the top-down problem
where you know actors like BlackRock the
world's largest asset manager you asked
who they are they're the world's largest
Asset Management over 10 trillion
dollars of everyday citizens money what
they do is they manage that money by
investing in American companies but then
to show up in the boardrooms of those
companies and say that you know what
We're Not Gonna
promote you yo we're not gonna pay you
or we're gonna vote your directors off
unless you adopt these environmental and
social agendas that we demand but
they're using the money of everyday
citizens
to do it most of those everyday citizens
actually disagree with that agenda so
that's the top down problem it's a you
know it's a big breach of fiduciary duty
using 10 trillion dollars of someone
else's money to advance political
agendas that the everyday citizen the
owner of capital disagrees with that's
the top down problem but the bottom-up
problem is we have a culture that's also
falling for it and saying that you know
what we actually do demand that
companies behave in ways that align with
our
neo-progressive values and then that
gives those boardrooms covered to be
able to say well this is what consumers
are demanding and that's what allows
Nike or Disney to behave in the way that
it does so it's complicated and so the
first book was basically well gang was
about the top down problem the problem
of the woke capitalist the use and abuse
the use I should say the abuse of
capital to be able to effectuate these
political agendas through the back door
that government couldn't effectuate
through the front door in that cynical
arranged marriage but but the second
half of it is this other problem the
generational cultural problem that the
victimhood cancer that's the heart of
nation of victims the next book that
explains this cultural uh deficit that
allows companies and government actors
to cynically prey on our cultural
insecurities as a generation and I think
that's equally an important part okay so
we'll we'll get to that in a sec because
I think that sort of the spiritual part
of this that I think many people are
missing right now they keep thinking the
answer to this problem is some sort of
government answer and it's like no
that's kind of how we got here uh but
just to jump back for a second you
mentioned the fiduciary responsibility
that these boards have to their
shareholders are you surprised or was
there an example of a company where the
shareholders were able to fight this
effectively I mean I remember literally
on my show five or six years ago when
Google AdSense was clamping down on
everybody I had a couple guests in a row
and I was calling for it too it's like
where are the shareholders who are going
well wait a minute put censorship aside
for a second if they are not putting ads
on certain things am I being hurt as a
shareholder like like was are there any
examples where the shareholders actually
accomplish anything or lawsuits or
anything
not a ton yet that's what I'm working on
man right all right I started to strive
subscribe as a new friend competing with
BlackRock we we just sent a public
letter to Chevron calling out a lot of
these you know a lot of these behaviors
that crucially though were forced on
them by BlackRock State Street and
Vanguard in many cases Chevron
said initially that they opposed these
proposals but then the large
shareholders vote for them anyway and
this is the problem Drew is that a lot
of a lot of the movement you know that
that you know you know you would you
would advocate for shareholder-centric
power what they miss is that the 21st
century version of this problem is
different and they've thrown a thrown a
tripwire that a lot of us fell for which
was that they said okay Milton Friedman
you said that shareholders rule right
and Company management teams report to
shareholders well guess what
we are the shareholder
we are demanding that you the company
management adopt these social agendas
you're not betraying your fiduciary duty
to us you're actually working for us
because we the shareholder Milton
Friedman all along said it Rule and you
owe the duty to us and we the
shareholders are demanding it so here's
the fallacy in that argument but but
that's that's effectively what allowed
this this problem to spread like
wildfire is the parlance of fiduciary
duty to shareholder misses the fact that
the shareholder I use shareholder air
quotes is actually the one pushing the
agenda so to do this we have to get a
little academic for a second dude
I got a bright audience
but okay so so the whole shareholder
Primacy Doctrine came from it was a
Vestige of 20th century corporate law
and and even Friedman I thinking in the
late 20th century that solved a problem
called the separation of ownership and
control okay so the CEO has control of
the firm but the shareholder owns The
Firm they're not the same person that
gives rise to what's called a principal
agent conflict the shareholders the
principal the CEO is the agent leads to
the private jet problem of you know CEOs
that are flying on private jets flying
using the shareholder Capital to do it
you know that RJR Nabisco problem
overspending well how do you close that
Gap it's by imposing a fiduciary duty on
the CEO to the shareholder so Milton
Friedman said the CEO can't pursue these
social agendas without serving interest
to the shareholder that's where the
fiduciary duty came from that's that's
20th century stuff it's called the
separation of ownership and control
the 21st century version of this problem
is different
it is not the separation of ownership
and control
it is the separation of ownership and
ownership
and what I mean by that is the parties
who now then claim to be the owners the
shareholders of these companies like
BlackRock State Street and Vanguard
they are not the actual owners of those
companies because they launched these
so-called passive index funds that
aggregated trillions of dollars in the
last 15 years
that or the money of everyday citizens
who are the actual owners of the company
but invest in vehicles that were managed
by a managerial Clinic that then showed
up in the boardrooms of those companies
and said you know what I am the
shareholder and I'm demanding you behave
this way but so basically in essence so
the average shareholder probably didn't
even know what was going on yeah they
didn't know what's going on so the way I
talk about
the everyday citizen whose money is
being invested
through a Plinko chips mediated
Financial system that then goes into a
pension fund that then asks an
investment consultant where to invest
that then invests in a fund manager by
BlackRock that then invests in a company
it's such an intermediated system but
the actual owner of capital has no idea
that that state pension fund and its
board member and its investment staff
and BlackRock were betraying their
interests by representing viewpoints in
corporate America's boardrooms in the
boardrooms of companies like Chevron the
one I wrote to earlier this week
in ways that the owner of capital had no
idea was actually happening so that's
really how this plays out in reality
where the parties who claim to be the
shareholders are not the actual
shareholders and that's the big problem
okay so with that in mind let's shift a
little bit to the sort of spiritual part
of this or the the generational the
cultural part that you're talking about
uh you mentioned before from uh Indian
background you grew up in the midwest I
mean I suspect that whether it was your
parents or great grandparents or
whatever it might be that came from
India I'm guessing they didn't come with
a lot and they probably had to worry and
I'm guessing that they don't feel very
guilty about your success no they don't
and that's the thing whether they're the
Republican Democrat the thing you'll
find about immigrants who come to this
country through the front door and I
distinguished that you know for coming
to the back of it legal immigrants in
front of by and large come to this
country to pursue Excellence to pursue
their dreams to pursue Excellence
without having to apologize for it
leaving places that were
anti-meritocratic to come to a
meritocratic nation where are regardless
of your Creed or skin color you can
achieve anything you want with your own
hard work and commitment and dedication
that used to be our national identity we
now have a new national identity built
on victimhood instead and one thing you
know my parents taught me from a young
age
is that hardship is not the same thing
as you're going to encounter hardship in
your life it's part of what teaches you
who you are
but we live now in a moment where where
kids are taught the Next Generation by
the way I know I was first generation my
parents were the immigrants I was born
in America the second and third
generation even though in the Asian
American communities are being taught
this new narrative to say that you know
what the more you think of yourself as a
victim as a person of color or whatever
your victim of narrative is that's how
you get ahead in life not by actually
unapologetically embracing the pursuit
of excellence and and that's become our
new national identity a national idea
that was built on the shared pursuit of
Excellence has since perverted into this
new national identity that that's taken
the form of this victimhood grievance
Olympics where there is no gold medalist
it is our nation and our national
identity that loses in the end and
that's the heart of this whole new book
you know that that's why I wrote the
book is someone who needed to expose
this in some ways as a first generation
American looking at this not as somebody
who inherited America but whose parents
came to this country voluntarily with
their two feet to to be part of that
national identity and yet now 40 years
later found a new national identity
centered on on this black hole of
victimhood instead
did did the neolibs or the libs or the
Neo progressives or whatever version
whatever language you want to use around
that is there some reason that they
inherently failed with this you know
that that they didn't defend the ideas
that their ancestors came here for well
enough
yes I think some of it was this
generational insecurity uh I think it's
this idea that when you haven't
encountered hardship actually you begin
to hunger for it
you know there's something about the
human psyche that's a funny thing we
require
hardship and the experience of
overcoming it to remind ourselves The
Contours of our soul of who we are I
gave the the high school commencement
address
to my own high school where I graduated
I gave convention when I graduated what
in 2003 they invited me back to give an
updated address last year at last year's
commencement and and it struck me that
was the first graduating class that had
an in-person graduation we're not a
single member of that class was even
born on the day that those twin those
Twin Towers were hit by those two planes
and that defined part of my high school
experience when I was in high school I
was AP History Class or U.S history
class at that particular time it was
you know it was it was a defining moment
this is you're looking at a generation
where not a single person had been
through that experience and I'm not
saying that it had to be 911 but
you know I think a generation that
actually has is on the receiving end of
that intergenerational wealth transfer
that hasn't had to necessarily as a
either as a citizen or as an individual
fight for the kind of right to be able
to be proud needs to then see themselves
as the victim of some other hardship
instead and so you could argue maybe
it's not even their fault this is just
what the Arc of History has dealt Our
Generation Millennials gen Z and younger
to have to think of themselves as
encountering hardships that don't even
actually exist and then reinvent that
victimhood narrative until a new one is
dealt in its place instead but the
problem is if you live in that
victimhood narrative for long enough
you're not even going to have the
fortitude to fight that hardship when it
actually comes maybe that's China maybe
it's something else whatever it is if we
don't turn this culture around I think
we will have actually lost the very
fortitude that we might have gotten from
actually encountering more part of the
diagnosis for me
yeah it's interesting you're making a
distinction that I try to bring up all
the time that it's that it's perceived
depression not necessarily even real
oppression that's right it's something
that's made up in there right so where
do you think big Tech fits in this you
know when we hear things like well okay
all of this gender stuff and all of this
woke stuff it's pushed on all of kids in
America through Tick Tock but it's
banned in China do you think that there
might be a connection there yeah or even
the China the parent company that owns
Tick Tock in China actually uses it to
like educate kids on math and science
and reading which is different than the
way we're educating people here so so
look I mean mostly when I'm talking
about you know big Tech or the term big
Tech I'm usually talking about the
censorship uh debate which you know a
views on but that's not what I'm going
to talk about here
this is a different issue and I think
I think it's an important one where
look one of the things I often say uh
not to get too philosophical here for
but will just for a second is that
virtue is not a product of capitalism
okay virtue is a precondition for
capitalism to do its work and what I
mean by that is that
look I I often a similar way of saying
that is capitalism would be the perfect
system for organizing a society's
Affairs if our wants actually matched
our needs
and to the extent that there's anything
wrong with it with with negative
externalities with capitalism it can
explain it can be explained entirely I
Believe by the daylight between our
wants and needs and I think part of what
the stakeholder capitalism movement gets
wrong is that it demands of these
capitalist actors
the need to cultivate virtue that should
have been cultivated through
institutions that predate capitalism
Capital into society the families yeah
religion whatever it is you know where
you pray national identity patriotisms
at the level of the community the level
of family absolutely so so so so what do
we see this play out as it relates to
tech companies and where does the debate
even get confused even by conservatives
over the last year for example was when
I saw the story break out by you know
the Wall Street Journal doing reporting
that um you know Facebook knew that the
young teen girls who were using
Instagram had body image insecurity
issues that were fueled and made worse
by Instagram and they didn't do anything
about it and uh by the way they knew
that they were making anger management
issues amongst their angry users even
worse but didn't do anything about it
and so you know conservative media
called me to talk about
about that issue because I had been a
long critic of censorship by big Tech
and so okay let's hit him hard they knew
it they didn't do anything about it
actually my view was actually no no
you're getting this all wrong actually
we should not as a society want Mark
Zuckerberg or Jack Dorsey to be our
priests and rabbis to Virtue in fact we
should want a society that cultivates
the kind of self-confidence among young
teen girls that don't leave them
vulnerable to the insecurities that
these algorithms are designed to prey on
and I think that we miss the fact that
we can cultivate that sense of psychic
fortitude and virtue in the offline
world so that these professionally
created algorithms aren't so well
equipped to pick at and pray on those
insecurities by knowing what you click
on versus what you don't click on and
use that to create a window to your soul
that sees your soul with greater Clarity
than you see yourself
that's just that's just the the
antecedent condition of the Divergence
of your want and need that deficit of
virtue that allowed the modern demonic
algorithmic version algorithm empowered
version of modern capitalism and and
Technology the industry part of it to
prey on those insecurities it's kind of
like the equivalent of a teeny girl in
the 1990s
you know a Virginia slim manufacturers
selling cigarettes to that teen girl who
had body image and security issues back
then it's the same thing all over again
when the thing we need to be addressing
is the generational insecurity in the
first place and cultivating that psychic
fortitude that actually allows
capitalism to then do its work to sell
us the goods and services we want more
effectively would we already have a
deep-seated self-confidence and
understanding of who we are as people
that predate cap our our identity as
capitalists and so this is one of the
solutions I talk about in the book is
you know one of the places I want to see
the conservative movement do better
is to provide an affirmative answer to
those questions about identity about
national identity about individual
identity and to talk not just about the
Revival of Freedom through system or
system of free market capitalism where
I'm one of the greatest champions for
exactly that model but also to talk
about a Revival of let's say civic
identity our identity as Citizens and
the psychic fortitude that we require as
Citizens and the civic duty that comes
in our capacity as a citizen from our
identity as just a capitalist who's a
participant in that economy and so what
did Big Tech do they called that bluff
This Modern social media called The
Bluff of a generation that didn't know
what they actually wanted and then
prayed on those psychic insecurities to
build multi-trillion dollar companies
that were not tech companies they were
psychologically they were
psychologically shrewd companies that
understood that they could understand
you better with their algorithms than
you could understand yourself and maybe
if you understood yourself even more
effectively that might have actually
prevented modern social media from
having the toxic effects that it since
had Rebecca am I a crazy conspiracy
theorist or is it possible that for all
those years that BuzzFeed had everyone
clicking on those nonsensical polls of
what do they like better this or that
that perhaps that had a little something
BuzzFeed and many of these other sites
but BuzzFeed which is now completely
collapsed was like the prime purveyor of
all of us clicking all these things and
they would as you sort of alluded to
there ultimately they would know what we
actually want more than we can even
understand that's not a conspiracy it's
a reality I mean look even look at Mark
Zuckerberg I mean his genius was not his
his technical aptitude the the
predecessor to Facebook I mean I was at
Harvard with him at the same time it was
a year ahead of me back then was hot or
not you know this or this so just sort
of taking these native base human
instincts and just picking at them and
exploiting them you know now does that
mean that we should we should regulate
the companies or prevent them from doing
that no no you're getting it all wrong
we need to revive the very institutions
at the level of the family at the level
of the nation at the level of the
community at the level of even uh
religious institutions to fill that void
of meaning and purpose and identity that
then prepares us for a society where
in free market capitalism we don't need
to apologize for the fact that some guy
ends up with more green pieces of paper
than the other who cares if we fetishize
those green pieces of paper what the
thing that really matters is that we
have Civic equality as Citizens that
we're grounded in the forms of identity
that really matter and that's where I
want to see the conservative movement do
better in stepping up to fill that void
in a way that it's completely abdicated
any interest in actually taking on
that's part of what motivated me to say
that you know I just wasn't done with
just woke ink you know nation of victims
was about taking a crack I'm not saying
I have all the answers but taking a
crack at
what fills that void of identity what
does it mean to be an American in the
year
2022 if we don't have a good answer to
that question maybe we as a movement
need to be stepping up Detroit and
answer that question or else you're just
going to have the same bla that same
poison continuing to fill that black
hole of a vacuum of identity rather than
just taking a jackhammer to sort of weed
out that poison one at a time maybe you
try a different strategy of diluting the
poison to irrelevance by filling it with
a new Rich vision for what that identity
could be that dilutes the poison to
irrelevance that's the approach I'm
interested in taking so so before we
finish with strive which is the
culmination of all this are are you
enthused or do you see markers that some
of what you're calling for is happening
I mean as you know I toured with Jordan
Peterson for two years the level of uh
exactly what you're asking for there in
terms of personal responsibility family
belief all of these things I mean he's
spreading that across the world I see
that coming now out of other corners of
conservatism so it's not just at
government off our back and low taxes
there's actually something more robust I
see that kind of happening do you do you
agree with that
yeah I I do I do see I do see a uh a
potential shift in the tide you know
it's interesting one of the things I I
uh cover in my in in nation of victims
the second book is
is actually I take a look at history not
just our National History A lot of it
goes into the parts of the Civil War
history that I hadn't reminded myself of
since high school
but even through a lot of Roman history
and one of the things I reminded myself
of is we often talk about the rise and
fall of Rome and then draw the analogies
to the rise and fall of the American
experiment
and and one of the things that I
reminded myself as part of the research
for the book and it you know it's in a
couple of the chapters there now is that
there was no one fall of Rome there were
many Rises and many faults and there
were moments in in what you thought
might have been the fall where the idea
of Rome reinvented itself right not just
the place but Rome was an idea in a
certain sense America was that idea both
were built on this idea of
exceptionalism in a certain sense you
couldn't even you know I I uh you know
again not to get waxed too philosophical
about it but but maybe Rome was reborn
maybe Rome was reborn in 1776 and I
think the idea of unapologetically
leading in the way that the American
experiment sought to lead these are
ideas Nations don't die the way that
human beings do they're constantly
reborn as something else I was actually
raised in a Hindu upbringing we weave
some Hindu philosophy into the book
about the idea of individual
reincarnation Into The Reincarnation of
the idea of a Nation The Reincarnation
of America itself you know what you know
it's not it's not it's not this
bilateral tug of war where the tie
either changing but rather if you look
through the Arc of History if you look
through the history of Rome and then
even look at the history of this own
country this country that we live in
that we consider ours it has an
opportunity to not just have one rise in
one fall but to constantly be reborn and
to ReDiscover itself and as there were
many Rises and Falls of Rome I predict
that there will be many Rises and Falls
of of this version of Rome of America as
well and I don't think that I'm
optimistic that we're not in we're in
what feels like a decline but is
actually just the beginning of a new
Revival and uh you know I hope we each
do our small part and play in a role in
making making that happen there's that
positivity I'm always looking for on
this show on the show so now bring us
home with strive because you don't just
talk about this stuff and just write
books about it you actually do real
world stuff and my audience is always
trying to figure out real ways to combat
this nonsense and I think they most of
my audience has done a lot of the the
spiritual and cultural work already so
they're ready for the hey what's the
business end of this thing well I think
some of this can be
I never imagined I was going to start
another business again but when I looked
at myself in the mirror and said look
how are we going to address this problem
I really saw an under utilized Avenue to
solve this through the market so strive
is a new investment firm we're competing
with BlackRock we're offering index
funds just like BlackRock does we listed
our first index fund and the New York
Stock Exchange last month
but the key difference is with a
different voice and vote to the table
where we tell companies to focus
exclusively on delivering excellent
products and services to their customers
over any other agenda social or
political agenda vaccination of victim
at the end of the subtitle of the book
is the path back to Excellence I think
part of the path back to Excellence runs
through the market that's actually what
strive is all about as well so just to
give it a tangible example the first
Index Fund we listed is a U.S energy
Index Fund it trades in the New York
Stock Exchange its ticker is drill and
it's a very simple message to to the U.S
energy industry you should drill Frack
do whatever allows you to be most
successful
without having to apologize for it if
that's what allows you to be successful
over the long run you don't need to
advance somebody else's social or
political agenda so that's why we pick
you know drll drills was uh to send a
very clear message but but I also want
to practice what I'm preaching and so so
you know that fund raised 300 million
dollars in its first three weeks its
first month or so of trading but it's
not just about doing this for the sake
of making a point it's to bring a
different shareholder voice to the table
and I was alluding this earlier that's
why you know even even in in recent days
sent a letter to the board of Chevron
questioning a lot of their politicized
behaviors that were influenced by the
likes of BlackRock but the problem is
that just to sit around and complain
about this well let's bring a different
shareholder voice to the table into the
boardroom and actually go back to
resolving these through free speech and
open debate both in the Public Square as
Citizens on political questions and then
back in the boardrooms bring real debate
back into the borders bring actual
diversity of thought something in the
name of diversity that we've missed in
Corporate America bring actual diversity
of thought back to the back to the
corporate boardroom to set this culture
right starting with our economy so
that's what I was doing with strive but
uh you know in some ways it's an
embodiment of what I wrote about not
just in woke Inc which is the problem
but even in nation of victims and the
path back to Excellence uh you know I
think I think hopefully you know it's
not there's no end all be all silver
bullet solution but I think Market
Solutions are going to be an important
part of it and that's where I chose to
focus my attention in the next chapter
love it man as simple as that we will
link to the book down below and I'd keep
you longer but you're clearly a busy guy
and you got things to do it was good to
see you man good to see you thank you
for having me we'll see you if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell